- And we're well in to
All The Feels February,
but let's be honest,
sometimes the feeling we
feel, is just annoyed, yep.
- Mm-hmm.
That happens, it's real, yep.
And as you know,
Sebastian can't stand people,
they bother him, so...
(laughs)
Even his loved ones so,
so it's time to play
something we're calling
I love you but please stop.
- [Lana] Mm-hmm
(upbeat music)
♪ I love you but please stop ♪
♪ Just stop ♪
(Kelly laughs)
- That's good.
- She ended it with, please stop.
Jessie, I love you.
We've loaded a bunch of
things that bother us
about those we love into
our random generator.
When I say go, the generator
will start flipping.
When one of us says, "I
love you, but please stop"
the generator will stop on a topic
and the person who said stop
will get 15 seconds to vent their heart,
I don't do that, I'm gonna be way longer
(Lana laughs)
I don't do synopsis.
Heart out on the topic though,
that we've been dealt with,
so are y'all ready?
- Yes
- Okay, don't fail.
Sebastian, you're first.
- Alright.
- Get the generator started, here we go.
- [Sebastian] I love you but please stop.
- Oh.
That's real.
- Okay, when she takes...
Listen, my wife, when we go out to eat,
takes forever to order,
she doesn't use her
menu time appropriately.
(audience laughs)
Okay?
So, I'm like, alright, but
like the waiter will come,
I'm like, "Alright babe."
She's like, "Alright, you go first"
so I'm like,
"Alright, I'll have steak
with mixed vegetables.
"Back to you."
How long did you think I was gonna take?
I mean, it was go first, not skydiving.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
So, stop it babe.
- That's true.
I have, I have one of those friends
that literally will be
like, "Is this gluten free
"or does this one have rice
in it or does this one..."
and I'm like, "Just eat at home."
(audience laughs)
Like, I'm hungry.
Eat at home, they don't
have food for you here.
Anyway, that's funny.
So Lana, you're next,
You ready?
- [Lana] Okay, mhmm.
Alright, lets get the
generator going again.
- [Lana] I love you, but please stop.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Wow, he's like agro.
When the tea is half full.
Okay so, my boyfriend, bless his heart,
I feel like this is gonna be like...
I don't wanna throw him under the bus,
It's okay, whatever
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Sebastian] Throw him.
- [Kelly] Throw him.
- So, he's very lovely and he gives me tea
and he brings me tea but
he always brings me tea,
that's like...
If this is the cup, this is
how much's water's in it,
and I--
- Does he not
want you to spill or...
- He says it's because
he doesn't wanna spill
as he brings it to me,
but I'm like, it's fine, it's just tea.
I want the full thing
because I'm not trying
to just get a taste.
I'm trying to get like,
the full experience
- That's just rude.
- I want the hydration
and it's like, but why?
- The hydration?
- It's true!
And I'm like, just then
don't bring it, right?
- Yeah.
- If it's this much.
- You know what, I'll get my own tea.
- [Lana] I'll get my, exactly
- Yeah, it's the little things
- [Lana] It's the little
things that are just like,
- Yeah.
- get ya.
- Yeah that would be weird.
That would be weird, okay my turn.
I'm not close to the button, here we go,
spin it, I'm ready, I will get up.
Please stop.
When the...
Oh, this is a real thing.
(audience laugh and agree)
Don't laugh at me.
It's a real thing.
I am so annoyed because
I like toilet paper,
and this is my house,
I'm talking about my house,
I like it coming over the top, people.
- Yes, yes
- That's what I'm taught.
(audience applaud and cheer)
And people,
come to my house...
- Yep.
This has happened, they come to my house
and they reverse it,
like it's their bathroom?
Like I'm like, I don't do,
I do that at their house
too though maybe, I do,
but I flip it,
but I'm like, you come to my house
and flip my toilet paper around?
I get there and I'm ready
and I'm like, (grunts)
I know it's a weird thing,
I hate the toilet paper...
Do you like it over or under?
- I like a loose roll.
- You like to pick it up from the ground.
- Pick it up, get a nice thing.
- All the bacteria, as much as you can.